the final journey for a young officer
who fought for her country and then with
cancer the turnout at major Mandy
Islam's funeral and nod to her
achievements on and off the front line
[Music]
Duty first even went sick she worked to
make life better for military personnel
with serious illness and she created an
online diary to track her battle with
cancer cancer isn't about something that
totally takes over from your life it's
about living high or happy saturday
welcome to cancer worry Diaries I
thought I'd do a video post that you can
see that I'm okay I took myself of
course thinking a couple of days at help
but by that evening I basically vomited
a pint of blood up this was her final
post Mandy had already been a soldier
for 10 years
by the time she arrived here at
Sandhurst age 26 to train to become an
officer unusually for a cadet she
already had three medals on her uniform
from tours in Iraq Northern Ireland and
Bosnia but this was a special place for
her not only is it where she honed her
leadership skills it's also where she
forged friendships a sisterhood with the
fellow female officers she served
alongside that sisterhood gathered at
the Sandhurst Memorial Chapel to
remember their friend she was always
positive always up for everything had a
real love for sports cars and speed and
adrenalin and and got that any which way
that she could
her love of life punched through even
when faced with death her dog Freddie
also standing proud gone but never
forgotten
Deborah Haynes Sky News at Sandhurst